so hello to all as many of you know in
late April the end of April 2019 my
family was flooded and we had to move
out of our house in a rush in 15 minutes
we lost everything that was in the
basement and we ended up having to leave
our house move into a new house that
we're renting and until now we are still
not back in our house it has been pretty
crazy if you follow me on social media
you'll see that I'm barely posting any
carvings because I'm not having been
able to get to carving I didn't have
space and also at some point my tools
and my stones were in different places
because we left so fast I had to gather
everything together luckily I've been
doing a lot of traveling doing a lot of
speaking events and so that has in a way
compensated for that but all of that is
over now
so we're I'm coming to a point where I
should start carving but now we have to
move again the place where we're renting
was a house that was for sale it has
been sold and within before the mid
August we have to leave and so all this
is kind of putting us in in in a whole
bunch of chaos so people have helped us
so much on through crowdfunding GoFundMe
people send me money directly we've been
able to amass a pretty good amount but
now it seems like we're going to have to
go back way if week we're probably gonna
have to go back to the house to our
house
and if we go back to our house it's
going to be considered a floodable area
and we do not want to put our kids back
in the basement and so on the one hand
we can't sell a house we have to go back
to our house on the other hand we have
to we have to find a way for us to be
able to live in that house because I we
had the rooms there we had my office
there and so it seems like the only
solution for us is to put a second floor
on the house and not use the basement
for anything important to kind of just
leave it as a general space or something
like that so that is a situation I mean
now and I and because I'm not able to
carve what I've decided to do and if
you've noticed I've been putting out a
lot of videos because I have time to do
it I've been making some drawings trying
to find other ways to maintain my
revenue stream so I've decided that
what I'm going to start doing from now
on is to put out one video a month that
is going to be only for patrons and the
subject is going to be traditional
stories fairy tales on the different
patronage platforms you can follow the
you can decide we'll be able to vote
which stories are going to be chosen but
for the first video I'm going to do the
secret meaning of Jack and the Beanstalk
which is already up right now for
patrons only
and we look at Jack and the Beanstalk
what its relation is to the story of
Jacob in the Bible what its relation is
to the notion of revolution and to the
problem of a hierarchy which prevents
the things from higher above how it can
prevent things from coming down and so
some interesting thought you can check
that out if you have been thinking of
supporting me financially for the past
year or whatever and you just haven't
gotten to it I would say that this would
be a good time to do it because because
I'm going to be focusing on the videos
until I find a permanent solution to get
back to carving the way it should be and
so once again everybody I thank you for
your continuing support both those that
have been helping us directly with the
GoFundMe campaign and those that are
supporting me on patreon I will try to
do my best to rise up to your
expectations of me and and so yeah check
out the the Jack in the Beanstalk video
if you are already a patron and if not
you can follow me through subscribe star
through my website or through patreon as
well so I will see you soon